different TV producers and filmmakers
have offered up their own takes on the
spooky family created by cartoonist
Charles Addams and some have worked a
lot better than others here then is
every major Addams Family movie and TV
series iteration ranked in order from
worst to best the 2019 animated The
Addams Family is everything in know
Addams Family Project has ever been loud
fast bright and moralizing this movie
feels less like an expansion of the
Addams universe and more like a lesser
Tim Burton animated project or a
knockoff of Adam Sandler's Hotel
Transylvania movies the characters are
given an unnecessary and clunky origin
story after an angry mob breaks up the
wedding of Gomez and Morticia because
they're too weird the loving couple runs
away to New Jersey with thing in tow
they take up residence in an abandoned
Asylum where they recruit mental patient
lurch to be their Butler flash forward
into the future and the Addams have
lived in sad isolation for more than a
decade there's also an awkward plot
about a reality TV host wanting to get
rid of this family that isn't bothering
anybody
and how Wednesday befriends that host
tween daughter and of course there's a
lesson about how it's a good thing to be
yourself the new Addams Family
inadvertently gives away its premise and
its title it's the same Addams Family as
the 1960s sitcom it's just new it plays
like a less than great eerie remake of
its predecessor with many of the actors
not so much interpreting their
characters but imitating their
counterparts from the 60 series Gomez
misses bills and the PTA just called me
hate obscene phone calls at least they
had the good sense to bring in original
Gomez John Astin as occasional character
grande Papa Addams but his presence just
reminded viewers of the greatness that
once was the only true innovation of the
new Addams Family is that it seemed to
take a cue from the early 90s Addams
Family movies and gave much more screen
time to Wednesday and Pugsley this early
90s animated cash-in on the popular
live-action movies aired on ABC Saturday
morning so it's obviously geared toward
children but the people who made it
focused so hard on having it be squeaky
clean that they lost the spirit of what
makes the Addams Family special those
screams were half
and I didn't hear his usual joyous
cackle sure the Adams is live in a
creepy shadowy mansion and yes Wednesday
and Uncle Fester liked to blow stuff up
whenever they get the chance but the
show leans too heavily on the family's
interactions with the outside world and
it's suffocating normalcy at least the
Addams Family the animated series for
stores and updates the 1960s sitcom
versions iconic snap happy theme song
and draws inspiration from the rich busy
look of the 1991 Addams Family film this
first animated take on The Addams Family
combines the charmingly grotesque look
of Charles Addams creations with the
voices and vaudevillian interplay of 60s
TV Gomez and Morticia all mixed in with
the trappings and cliches of 70s
Saturday morning cartoons that is to say
the animation is cheap and stilted there
are wacky animal sidekicks and every
joke is met with a braying laugh track
this Addams Family feels an awful lot
like scooby-doo where are you
they even crossed over at one point only
it embraces the spooky instead of
unmasking it like the mysteries
Incorporated gang this version of The
Addams Family also drives around
endlessly not in a van but a creepy
camper which looks like they miniaturize
their mansion and put it on top of a
hearse they cause a stir in a new
location in every episode and true -
Addams Family spirits they're oblivious
to how the way they do things is not the
way the rest of the world does things
when Raul Julia the actor who played
gomez addams in the hit 90s films passed
away the chance for a successful Addams
Family trilogy seemed to be lost what
fans eventually got was Addams family
reunion a franchise reboot in the form
of a direct-to-video movie it doesn't
stand up to the other films and it's
decidedly b-level production values the
plot is a little weak too involving the
Addams is attending the incorrect family
reunion by mistake and getting mixed up
in a guy's killing for inheritance
scheme while it lacks a lot of the dark
comedy and joyful playfulness of the two
Addams Family movies that preceded it
it's agreeable and family-friendly and
the filmmakers wisely cast the great Tim
Curry in the role of Gomez
while Darrell henna turns in a
serviceable Morticia there were a lot of
weird sitcoms in the 60s and many of
them were built around fish-out-of-water
scenarios The Addams Family took a
different approach let the water come to
the fish The Addams lived in a gigantic
19th century mansion full of sentient
plants suits of armor a lion and more
enjoying each other's company and
occasionally dealing with the stuffy
local conservative figures who populated
the generic town outside its doors
they also casually tossed off references
to death darkness and the McCobb which
certainly wasn't happening on Gilligan's
Island this is going to be the greatest
train wreck and railroad history the
same track mortician knits or paints
while gomez fences Texas stocks and
deals mildly in the dark arts which
occurs between the couples ferocious
displays of affection if Charles Addams
original creations were meant to be a
thorough contrast to the strictures of
modern life the TV series helped get the
point across when the Addams Family made
the leap to the big screen in 1991 all
the Adams quirks and the franchise's
tropes were amped up without taking it
too far
Morticia is more elegant and enigmatic
than ever
Gomez is bursting with a zest for life
and death Uncle Fester is downright
frightening and Wednesday is just
casually unflinchingly interested in
torture and mayhem
[Music]
these characters are allowed to finally
embrace the behaviors and activities
only hinted at in other Adams family
media while the film's big-budget
affords a realistically rendered thing
which expressively darts around the
atoms gloriously well-appointed but
decaying mansion
moreover the prevailing message of
Adam's family shows up the past is more
clearly conveyed in both the Addams
Family and 1993's Addams Family Values
the people in this family aren't the
creeps it's the modern world with its
forced cheerfulness and scams with a
smile that's truly villainous check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]